Lo que discuto es la conclusión que muchas personas sacan de eso,
como que todos estamos jodidos
porque los problemas no tienen solución
y nuestros gobiernos son inútiles.
Pero, ¿por qué digo esto?
No es que sea especialmente optimista por naturaleza.
Pero algo en los constantes malos augurios de los medios
con su fijación en los problemas y no en las soluciones
siempre me ha molestado.
Por eso hace unos años me dije,
bien, soy periodista,
debería ver si puedo hacerlo mejor
e ir por el mundo preguntándole a la gente
si abordaron y cómo lo hicieron
sus grandes desafíos económicos y políticos.
Y encontré algo que me sorprendió.
Resulta que hay notables señales de progreso en el mundo,
a menudo en los lugares más inesperados,
y me han convencido de que nuestros grandes desafíos globales
pueden no ser tan irresolubles después de todo.
No solo hay soluciones teóricas;
esas soluciones se han probado.
Han funcionado.
Y ofrecen esperanza para el resto de nosotros.
Mostraré lo que quiero decir
contándoles cómo tres de los países que visité
-- Canadá, Indonesia y México --
superaron tres problemas supuestamente imposibles.
Sus historias importan porque tienen herramientas que podemos usar,
y no solo para esos problemas particulares,
sino para muchos otros también.
Cuando la mayoría piensa en mi tierra natal, Canadá, hoy en día,
si es que piensan en Canadá,
piensan en frío, piensan en algo aburrido, en algo educado.
Piensan que decimos demasiado "lo siento" con nuestros acentos divertidos.
Y todo eso es cierto.
(Risas)
Lo siento.
Pero Canadá también es importante
por su triunfo sobre un problema
que actualmente desgarra a muchos otros países:
la inmigración.
Hoy Canadá es una de las naciones más receptivas del mundo,
incluso en comparación con otros países proinmigración.
Su tasa de inmigración per cápita es cuatro veces mayor que la de Francia,
y su porcentaje de residentes nacidos en el extranjero
es el doble del de Suecia.
Mientras tanto, Canadá admitió
10 veces más refugiados sirios el año pasado
que Estados Unidos.
(Aplausos)
Y ahora Canadá está acogiendo aún más.
Y, sin embargo, si le preguntan a los canadienses
qué les da más orgullo de su país
dirán el "multiculturalismo",
una mala palabra en la mayoría de los lugares,
segundo,
por delante del hockey.
El hockey.
(Risas)
En otras palabras, en un momento en que otros países
construyen frenéticamente nuevas barreras para expulsar extranjeros,
los canadienses quieren recibir aún más.
Lo interesante de esto
es que Canadá no siempre fue así.
Hasta mediados de 1960, Canadá siguió una política explícitamente racista.
La llamaron "Canadá Blanca",
y como se puede ver, no hablaban solo de la nieve.
Entonces, ¿cómo Canadá se convirtió en la Canadá de hoy?
A pesar de lo que diría mi madre en Ontario,
la respuesta no estuvo vinculada a la virtud.
Los canadienses no somos inherentemente mejores que cualquier otra persona.
La explicación real está en el líder de Canadá en 1968;
Pierre Trudeau, que es también el padre del actual primer ministro.
(Aplausos)
Lo que hay que saber de Trudeau
es que era muy diferente de los líderes anteriores de Canadá.
Era un francófono en un país ampliamente dominado por su élite inglesa.
Era intelectual.
Era un groovy.
En serio, el tipo hizo yoga.
Pasó mucho tiempo con los Beatles.
(Risas)
Y como todo hípster, podía ser irritante a veces.
Pero, no obstante, realizó
una de las transformaciones más progresistas de un país antes vista.
Su fórmula que he aprendido, constaba de dos partes.
Primero, Canadá eliminó viejas reglas de inmigración basadas en la raza,
y las reemplazó por nuevas leyes agnósticas al color
con hincapié en educación, experiencia y conocimientos de idiomas.
Eso aumentó en gran medida las probabilidades
de que los recién llegados contribuyeran a la economía.
La segunda parte, Trudeau creó la primera política del mundo
de multiculturalismo oficial para promover la integración
y la idea de que la diversidad fue la clave de la identidad de Canadá.
En los años siguientes, Ottawa siguió con este mensaje,
pero, al mismo tiempo, los canadienses de a pie
pronto empezaron a ver beneficio económico y material en la multiculturalidad
a su alrededor.
Y estas dos influencias pronto se combinaron
para crear la pasión de mente abierta de la Canadá actual.
Pasemos ahora a otro país y un problema aún más difícil,
el extremismo islámico.
En 1998, el pueblo de Indonesia salió a las calles
y derrocó a su dictador eterno, Suharto.
Fue un momento increíble,
pero también aterrador.
Con 250 millones de personas,
Indonesia es el país más grande de mayoría musulmana en el planeta.
También es caliente, enorme e ingobernable,
está formado por 17 000 islas,
donde se hablan unas mil lenguas.
Suharto había sido un dictador
desagradable.
Pero también un tirano bastante efectivo,
y siempre había mantenido la religión fuera de la política.
Los expertos temían que, sin su control sobre las cosas,
el país explotara
o los extremistas religiosos pudieran tomar el poder
y hacer de Indonesia una versión tropical de Irán.
Y eso es justo lo que parecía que pasó en un primer momento.
En las primeras elecciones libres, en 1999,
los partidos islamistas obtuvieron el 36 % de los votos,
las islas ardieron
por disturbios y ataques terroristas que mataron a miles.
Desde entonces, sin embargo, Indonesia ha dado un giro sorprendente.
Mientras que la gente común se ha vuelto más piadosa a nivel personal
-- vi muchos más pañuelos en una reciente visita,
que hace una década --
la política del país se ha movido en la dirección opuesta.
Indonesia es ahora una democracia bastante decente.
Y sin embargo, sus partidos islamistas han ido perdiendo apoyo,
desde un máximo de un 38 % en 2004
hasta un 25 % en 2014.
En cuanto al terrorismo, ahora es extremadamente raro.
Y mientras que algunos indonesios se han unido recientemente a ISIS,
su número es pequeño,
mucho menor en términos per cápita
que el número de belgas.
Traten de pensar en otro país de mayoría musulmana
del que se pueda decir lo mismo.
En 2014, fui a Indonesia para preguntarle a su actual presidente,
un tecnócrata de voz suave llamado Joko Widodo,
"¿Por qué prospera Indonesia mientras otros estados musulmanes mueren?"
"Bueno, nos dimos cuenta", me dijo,
"de que para abordar el extremismo, hay que resolver primero la desigualdad".
Vean, los partidos religiosos indonesios, como los similares en otros lugares,
se centraron en reducir la pobreza y la corrupción.
Eso hicieron Joko y sus predecesores,
arrebatándole la posta a los islamistas.
También reprimieron con fuerza el terrorismo,
pero los demócratas indonesios han aprendido una lección clave
de los años oscuros de la dictadura,
que la represión solo crea más extremismo.
Por eso libraron su guerra con extraordinaria delicadeza.
Usaron la policía en vez del ejército.
Solamente detenían sospechosos si tenían suficientes pruebas.
Hicieron juicios públicos.
Incluso enviaron imanes liberales a las cárceles
para persuadir a los yihadistas de que el terror es antiislámico.
Y todo esto valió la pena de manera espectacular,
creando un tipo de país inimaginable hace 20 años.
Así que en este punto, mi optimismo debería, espero,
empezar a tener un poco más de sentido.
Ni la inmigración ni el extremismo islámico son imposibles de tratar.
Acompáñenme en un último viaje,
esta vez a México.
De nuestras tres historias, esta probablemente me sorprendió más,
ya que como todos saben,
el país todavía enfrenta muchos problemas.
Y, sin embargo, hace unos años, México hizo algo
que muchos otros países, desde Francia hasta India o EE. UU.
todavía solo pueden soñar.
Rompieron la parálisis política en que estaban hacía años.
Para entender cómo, hay que remontarse al año 2000,
cuando México finalmente se convirtió en una democracia.
En lugar de usar sus nuevas libertades para luchar por la reforma,
los políticos de México las usaron para luchar entre sí.
El Congreso entró en punto muerto, y los problemas del país
-- las drogas, la pobreza, la delincuencia, la corrupción --
se escaparon del control.
Las cosas se pusieron tan mal que en el 2008,
el Pentágono advirtió que México corría el riesgo de colapso.
Luego, en 2012, Enrique Peña Nieto
de alguna manera llegó a presidente.
Al principio, Peña no inspiró mucha confianza.
Claro, era guapo,
pero venía del corrupto antiguo partido gobernante de México, el PRI,
y era un célebre mujeriego.
De hecho, parecía un niño tan bonito
que las mujeres lo llamaban "bombón", dulzura,
en los mítines de campaña.
Y, sin embargo, este mismo bombón pronto sorprendió a todos
negociando una tregua
entre los tres partidos políticos beligerantes del país.
Y en los siguientes 18 meses, aprobaron juntos
un conjunto de reformas increíblemente amplio.
Desarticularon los sofocantes monopolios mexicanos.
Liberalizaron el oxidado sector energético.
Reestructuraron sus escuelas deficientes, y mucho más.
Para apreciar la escala de este logro,
traten de imaginar al Congreso de EE.UU. aprobando la reforma de inmigración,
la reforma de la financiación de campañas y la reforma de la banca.
Ahora, traten de imaginar al Congreso haciendo todo eso al mismo tiempo.
Eso hizo México.
No hace mucho, me encontré con Peña y le pregunté cómo manejó todo.
El presidente me lanzó su famosa sonrisa chispeante
(Risas)
y me dijo que la respuesta corta era "compromiso".
Por supuesto, le pedí más detalles,
y la respuesta más larga fue esencialmente:
"Compromiso, compromiso y más compromiso".
Peña sabía que necesitaba construir confianza temprana,
así que empezó a hablar con la oposición pocos días después de ser electo.
Para protegerse de la presión de los intereses especiales,
mantuvo sus reuniones pequeñas y secretas,
y muchos de los participantes luego me dijeron que esta intimidad,
y mucho tequila compartido,
ayudaron a construir confianza.
También el hecho de que las decisiones tenían que ser unánimes,
y que Peña incluso acordó aprobar prioridades políticas del otro partido
antes que las propias.
Como me dijo Santiago Creel, un senador de la oposición,
"Mira, no digo que yo sea especial o que alguna persona es especial,
pero ese grupo, era muy especial".
¿La prueba?
Cuando Peña prestó juramento, se concretó el pacto,
y México avanzó por primera vez en años.
Bueno.
Hemos visto cómo estos tres países
superaron tres de sus grandes desafíos.
Y eso es muy bueno para ellos, ¿verdad?
Pero ¿qué tiene de bueno para nosotros?
En el curso del estudio de estas y muchas otras historias de éxito,
como la recuperación de Ruanda tras la guerra civil,
o Brasil, que ha reducido la desigualdad,
o Corea del Sur cuya economía sigue creciendo más rápido y por más tiempo
que cualquier otro país del mundo,
he notado algunos puntos en común.
Pero antes de describirlos, tengo que hacer una advertencia.
He notado, claro, que cada país es único.
No se puede tomar lo que funcionó en uno,
llevarlo a otro y esperar que funcione también.
Tampoco las soluciones específicas funcionan para siempre.
Hay que adaptarlas según cambian las circunstancias.
Dicho eso, yendo a la esencia de estas historias,
se pueden extraer algunas herramientas en común para solucionar problemas
que funcionarán en otros países
y en las salas de juntas
y en otros contextos, también.
Número uno, adopta lo extremo.
En todas las historias que analicé,
la salvación llegó en un momento de peligro existencial.
Y eso no fue coincidencia.
Veamos Canadá: cuando asumió Trudeau, enfrentó dos peligros inminentes.
Primero, a pesar de que su país enorme y poco poblado
necesitaba desesperadamente más gente,
su fuente preferida de trabajadores blancos, Europa,
había dejado de exportarlos al recuperarse finalmente de la II Guerra Mundial.
El otro problema era que la larga guerra fría de Canadá
entre sus comunidades francesa e inglesa
ya era una guerra caliente.
Quebec amenazaba con separarse,
y los canadienses mataban a otros canadienses por política.
Los países enfrentan crisis todo el tiempo, ¿cierto?
Eso no es nada especial.
Pero el genio de Trudeau estuvo en darse cuenta de que la crisis de Canadá
había barrido todos los obstáculos que suelen bloquear la reforma.
Canadá tenía que abrirse. No tenía otra opción.
Y tenía que replantearse su identidad.
De nuevo, no tenía otra opción.
Y eso le dio a Trudeau una oportunidad única en una generación
de romper las viejas reglas y escribir otras nuevas.
Y como todo héroe, fue inteligente como para aprovecharla.
Número dos, hay poder en el pensamiento promiscuo.
Otra similitud sorprendente entre los buenos solucionadores de problemas
es que son todos pragmáticos.
Roban las mejores respuestas de donde las encuentran,
y no dejan que los detalles
como partido, ideología o sentimentalismo se interpongan en su camino.
Como ya mencioné antes, los demócratas indonesios fueron inteligentes
como para robarle las mejores promesas de campaña a los islamistas.
Incluso invitaron a algunos de los radicales a su coalición de gobierno.
Eso horrorizó a muchos indonesios seculares.
Pero obligar a los radicales a ayudar realmente a gobernar,
rápidamente expuso el hecho de que no eran buenos para el trabajo,
y los mezcló en la maraña de compromisos
y las pequeñas humillaciones que son parte de la política cotidiana.
Eso perjudicó tanto su imagen que nunca se recuperaron.
Número tres,
contentar a cada uno, en algún momento.
Acabo de contar que las crisis pueden dar libertades extraordinarias a los líderes.
Y eso es cierto, pero resolver problemas a menudo requiere algo más que audacia.
Requiere mostrar moderación, también,
justo cuando es lo último que uno quiere hacer.
Ejemplo Trudeau: al asumir el cargo,
fácilmente podría haber puesto su base electoral,
es decir, la comunidad francesa de Canadá, en primer lugar.
Podría haber complacido a algunos todo el tiempo.
Y Peña podría haber usado su poder para seguir atacando a la oposición,
como era tradición en México.
Sin embargo, en su lugar eligió abrazar a sus enemigos,
y obligó a su propio partido a comprometerse.
Y Trudeau hizo que todo el mundo dejara de pensar en términos tribales
y viera el multiculturalismo, no el idioma ni el color de la piel,
como la quintaesencia de lo canadiense.
Nadie tuvo todo lo que quería,
pero todo el mundo tuvo lo justo tras negociar.
En este momento estarán pensando:
"Bien, Tepperman,
si las soluciones están a la vista como sigues insistiendo,
¿por qué no hay más países que las usen?"
No hacen falta poderes especiales para lograrlo.
Es decir, ninguno de los líderes que acabamos de ver eran superhéroes.
No consiguieron nada por su cuenta,
y todos tuvieron muchos defectos.
Por ejemplo, el primer presidente democrático de Indonesia,
Abdurrahman Wahid.
Este hombre tenía tan poco carisma
que en una ocasión se quedó dormido
en medio de su propio discurso.
(Risas)
Es verdad.
Esto nos dice que el verdadero obstáculo no es la capacidad,
y no son las circunstancias;
es algo mucho más simple.
Hacer grandes cambios implica asumir grandes riesgos,
y asumir grandes riesgos, da miedo.
Superar el miedo requiere coraje
y, como todos saben,
los políticos con agallas son especies raras.
Pero eso no quiere decir que como votantes
no exijamos coraje a nuestros líderes políticos.
Es decir, para eso los pusimos en el cargo, en primer lugar.
Y dado el estado actual del mundo, no hay realmente otra opción.
Las respuestas están allí,
ahora depende de nosotros
elegir más mujeres y hombres
con coraje suficiente para que las encuentren,
las roben
y las pongan en acción.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)